all right well welcome back uh we're now
gonna walk through the the lab on
multiple testing and of course the first
thing that we do whenever we sit down at
our computers is that we should set a
random seed so that um you'll get the
same results that we get so here i see
the six
and now we're going to simulate some
data and the data is going to correspond
to 100 hypothesis tests each of these
hypothesis tests is going to be that the
mean of a particular vector equals 0.
let's create this matrix x and so what
we have here is a matrix x with 10 rows
and 100 columns each column corresponds
to hypothesis that we're going to test
which is that the elements of that
column have mean 0. and right now this x
matrix all of its elements are normal 0
1.
but we're going to modify the first
columns of x so that their mean is
actually 0.5 so that's what we've done
here we've taken the first 50 columns of
x and we've added 0.5 to each of those
first 50 columns
and again we're going to test the null
hypothesis that for each of the 100
columns of x the null hypothesis or
rather the mean is zero so we can use
the t dot test command to
test the null hypothesis on let's say
the the first column here
and you see that when we do this we get
some output and in particular the
p-value is 0.07 so for this first column
did the null hypothesis hold or did it
not hold i can't remember so for the
first column it did not hold oh then all
hypothesis did not hold hmm but we got a
p-value of what now
0.07 so
just because we get a slightly larger
p-value of course doesn't guarantee that
the null hypothesis is that's true so
this is actually a um a guilty criminal
but we failed to
reject the null hypothesis that they're
innocent right and because we didn't get
evidence beyond reasonable doubt that's
right there's still a reasonable doubt
we happen to know because we simulated
the data that the null hypothesis does
not hold for this first column but our
p-value doesn't doesn't show us that in
this case
so that's how we're going to test the
hypothesis for the first column but
we're going to now make a for loop to
test the null hypothesis for all 100
columns right yep and so now what we're
going to do is look at which of these
p-values were less than five percent and
which ones were greater
and so to do that we first create a
vector uh with a hundred elements in it
each one that says do not reject the
null hypothesis
and then we go through and select out
the elements where the p-value is less
than five percent change that to a
rejection decision
and here's the table
of counting all the various
possibilities and this corresponds to
the tables we were looking at in the
slides and of course because this is
simulated data and we know the truth we
can actually calculate all four
components of that table
and so for example here the situations
where we manage to reject the null
hypothesis even though the null
hypothesis is true that's this three
here that corresponds to the the type
one errors that we had previously
so this this two by two table that um
gareth just created for us it looks like
those two by two tables from the lecture
although notice that like a couple of
the columns have been swapped like left
right and up and down so you got to look
carefully to understand how this
corresponds to those tables from the
lecture so in particular though v here v
is the number of false rejections or
type one errors
v is what now gareth
three three
and why
how can we conceptualize the fact that
it's three like what would we have
expected it to be if we're rejecting so
let's think about this
um we we're rejecting any null
hypothesis for which the p-value is less
than 0.05 and there were 50 null
hypotheses
so we would expect about two and a half
uh
that we falsely reject so yeah we
expected her falsely object around two
and a half we actually falsely rejected
around three does that pass the sniff
test
seems reasonable seems reasonable yeah
so we have three false rejections and
then we can feel really happy about the
fact
that out of the
um
well let's see the null hypothesis was
true for 50. so we had three false
rejections
and then that means of course 47 that we
didn't falsely reject
um so that's good but we we can't
actually feel so good about what's
happening in that leftmost column
because out of the 50 null hypotheses
that didn't hold
we only managed to reject for ten of
them
yep and
that was because the
even though they didn't hold uh they
weren't too far off from from the truth
and so we didn't have enough data to be
really sure to reject them remember we
only have 10 observations here for each
of these hypotheses so like remember we
have that p value of 0.07
even though we happen to know in our
hearts because we simulated the data
that that null hypothesis was false for
the first column
uh we weren't able to reject h naught
for that first column and that shows up
in that top left corner here so those
are like 40 failures to reject so the
bottom line here with this two by two
table is that um out of the times that
the null hypothesis held out of the
hypothesis for which the null hypothesis
held we only falsely rejected three
times out of 50 and that's again what we
would expect based on controlling the
type one error at level alpha equals
0.05 so that's good news
um and then the bad news that's a little
bit disappointing is that out of the 50
null hypothesis
or rather the 50 hypotheses where the
null hypothesis didn't hold we actually
only successfully rejected 10 times and
that's just really because for the other
40 times that the null hypothesis didn't
hold we just didn't quite have that
preponderance of evidence that we need
to reject at level 0.05 and that's
because even though the null hypothesis
didn't hold for those 50 the we were
only 0.5 different the means were only
differed by 0.5 or rather that the mean
was only 0.5 away from the null
hypothesis right and and so so not a
very strong signal as we sometimes talk
about in hypothesis testing so let's
repeat this uh calculation very quickly
but with a larger mean difference for
the
150 where the null hypothesis doesn't
hold instead of using 0.5 we'll use one
here
and repeat everything else
we'll recalculate the p values
and recalculate the table
and now what do we see well now i'm a
lot happier because out of the 50
null hypotheses that did not hold so
that's the look in the first column h
naught was false 50 times
we actually successfully rejected 41
times out of 50. so that's really good
excellent now what about the right hand
column though gareth what's going on
well so of the situations where ho was
true there's actually was actually only
one time where
we rejected the null hypothesis so
that's pretty good as well and that
discrepancy between the three that we
got before and the one that we have now
how can what can we chalk that up too
just a random variation in the
hypotheses random variation yeah we
would expect on average again um to be
rejecting falsely rejecting the null
hypothesis two and a half times on
average so that bottom right number
should be something around two and a
half um it was three the first
time yeah got a little bit lucky all
right okay so the next thing we're going
to do then is talk about the family-wise
error rate and one of the plots that we
showed was with a simplified calculation
where we assumed that the null
hypothesis were all independent from
each other and calculated for differing
values of m what the family-wise error
rate looked like and so i'm going to
reproduce that plot here it's a
relatively simple calculation make a
vector m from 1 to 500
and then we're just applying the same
formula that was in the slides for
different values of alpha and then i'm
just going to
plot these three curves
now we have our first plot
and our second and our third so these
correspond to the three different values
of alpha here and you can see again that
as m gets larger and larger the family
y0 rate rapidly goes up towards one
except for maybe the green line when
alpha's really small but eventually even
that one would get close to one so just
emphasizing that for large values of m
it's very hard to control the family y
zero rate
and oh here's the five percent cut off
okay so now now we're going to move on
and look at those fund fund manager data
the five fund managers and this data is
in the islr2 library so we're going to
load in that library
and we're going to start off by
looking at the
the data set itself has thousands of
fund managers in it but we're just
looking at the first five here so i've
just subset subseted off the first five
fund managers
calculated a t-test for the
first of those fund managers and you can
see here the p-value is .006 which is
what we saw in the slides previously so
this is just matching the data that we
had before we're going to calculate the
p values for all five of these managers
and it's going to print them on the
screen here so you can see these again
are the five p values that we saw
previously in the slides and we can see
fund managers one and three have the
smallest p values and fund managers two
four five have very underwhelming p
values definitely wouldn't stick with
those ones
so now we're going to
apply the bonferroni and holm methods
and fortunately we don't have to be very
clever in implementing these methods in
r because r does the calculation for us
automatically using this p dot adjust
function
so
how does this work so if i use p dot
adjust i feed it the p values and then i
just tell it method equals one for only
and it automatically adjusts the p
values and essentially all it's doing
really is multiplying them by m
and cutting off at one time where m is
the number of tests right exactly so in
this case m is five and if you look at
this all it's done is just multiply each
one of my p values by five in some cases
that would result in a value greater
than one so it just caps it at one and
you can just emphasize that i've done a
little calculation here where i've just
manually done the same thing and you can
see it's identical to the bonferroni
okay and then just the the final one
here using the whole method home home
was a little more complicated to
describe but it's actually trivial to
calculate an r because again we use
exactly the same command and just tell
method equals home
and it makes those adjustments and you
can see that the
smallest p-value the one associated with
fund manager one hasn't changed at all
here which is what you'll always see
with home but the really important one
is fund manager three where the p-value
using bonferroni the adjusted p-value if
you like was just a bit above five
percent and now using home it's a little
bit below five percent so this is why we
can now reject at least at the five
percent level of significance the null
hypothesis for fund manager three so
we're happy we're happy as you all know
by now i'm lazy so i prefer bonferroni
to home i know that gareth is on team
home um but what i will also tell you is
like 0.05 this is just like an arbitrary
threshold for family wise error rate
and like
you know the idea that we would be
rejecting for fund manager one
if we use home because that adjusted p
value is just barely below 0.05 but
using bonferroni we wouldn't reject that
sort of shows how arbitrary these
cut-offs are
yup
there's nothing magic about 0.05
but it also emphasizes that this
bonferroni number is probably of 0.058
is is probably a a little more negative
than it needs to be a little more
conservative yeah we can actually we can
be a little more sure than bonferroni
suggesting about fund manager three well
i don't feel sure
okay
i feel a little emotional he feels more
sure than i do
but neither of us are investing in him
so it doesn't matter that's true yeah he
works at a business school i'm only
going to do what he tells me to do
when it comes to investing